I'm just intensely
curious about people and social behavior.
Everything that I'm doing
is just my way of satisfying
that curiosity.
My work as a photographer
is deeply rooted in culture.
I'm really excited to travel to Fort Worth
to explore all the old Western traditions
that make the city what it is.
Okay, this is where the magic starts.
Can I take some pictures
as you’re doing it? Sure.
Absolutely.
When I start shooting a project,
I just like to arrive in a place
and really just follow my intuition.
I don't really have a plan.
That's very exciting, actually.
I'm most excited to photograph
the longhorn cattle drive,
which I've only heard about,
and it's one of the most unique traditions
in Fort Worth.
Good morning.
I'm Kristin. Welcome to Fort Worth.
Have you been around Texas
longhorn cattle before?
Never.
Everything that I've seen,
it's been almost a little surreal.
I've never seen this in real life.
I’ve seen it only in Western movies.
But what's unique about their breed
is they're all different colors,
different sizes.
He's a miniature steer.
He's actually our 2022 world champion
miniature.
It's very distinguished.
Some of their horns are going up.
Some are straight out. Some are twisting.
And they grow
throughout their entire life.
So they're just
magnificent steers.
I didn't realize the horns
are going to be so huge and so beautiful.
They're bigger than life huge.
And we'll go out the gray gate.
The reason why we do this is we're
commemorating a time in history
when Longhorns were driven
through Fort Worth along what's called
the Chisholm Trail.
So we're preserving Western heritage,
the American cowboy,
and, of course, the Texas Longhorn.
Joining the herd today is really just
an incredible experience to witness.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
Yes, ma'am.
I mean, one of my favorite things
about travel
is that it opens my eyes
to new experiences and new cultures.
That was amazing to watch.
It was like a dance.
I really can't wait to get back to Texas
and have more adventures here.